[Music]
music care check arts care check drake
care check selfies care double check
Coachella care Marty feeling really
cleanse by this desert is so cleanse I'm
just feeling like you generally
free-spirited and open you know it
really is like a big 90,000 person
family okay bro I know on our itinerary
I didn't have this sketch till Toro y
Moi hits those opening synth chord Eidos
but we poppin the T vibes are just too
strong gay yeah we gotta pop the t's
incredible call well bro you're going
straight to chesty yeah I took my shirt
out of transition tank what's a
transition tan Guerra I'm sorry I
thought you said you've coach showed
before horse I've coach owed
I've also la load bond owed and snow
bison bro you can't go straight to look
and thin show and skin without hitting
the key transitional state of sun's out
guns
first off I'm definitely not looking fin
showing skin I'm sportin chest feeling
well yeah right jacket a tank top is
like drawing your guns at a shootout
with the safety stolen question yeah do
you see anything safe about this boom
boom boom boom boom I call this the
dancing curl emoji gear boom gross you
look like a reject from the Magic Mike
double XL auditions
oh no transition tank epic fail you
clown Gary you just got annihilated by a
stranger whoa wait bro if you listen
closely I think I think I can hear all J
playing I think that's a power generator
no no bro are you sure that's not the
course to breezeblocks definitely a
power job yeah yeah I know it you're
right okay I say we go fill up our camel
pack and then hit up the main Stowe
actually bro I'm I'm have a other plans
for my camel pack I understand did you
sneak in boots why is the lying why is
the line going down into your shoe oh oh
no no really Quinn why because bro while
you're like waiting in line tonight for
the porta-potties I'm gonna be front and
center walking eyes the Drake both of us
just like letting it flow I can't
[Music]
Pinchas grab the pack oh my god I got
pee I got pee on my on my lad that's so
gross hey could you guys help me
who's the Canadian band playing this
freakin that everyone says not to miss
uh I guess that depends what kind of
music are you and your girlfriend into
uh uh oh no no she's not my girlfriend
my boyfriend's I'm a Huber oh wow sorry
about my friend he's new to coach Oh a
human uber
I'm so drunk do you like have any water
Kirkland can you please help me out
actually I'm pretty notorious I music
Twitter how god Guerra known to take
music debates from the time line into
the DMS and back again Gary stop talking
there's just so many great Canadian
bands is he boring wrong on all accounts
she wants what everybody wants
Aubrey Graham she specifically said bank
drake is neither band nor artist he
rules the iron throne of all musical
genres with songs that are equal parts
ice and fire the king of the north
you know the seat of House Stark is
antha Khaleesi up the sick because it
makes no sense Khaleesi means while
allegiance to the house ovo coat of arms
the owl house motto yellow who burg I
passed the Ox guard auto-play Iggy
Azalea I had a music festival
what are you doing they've been texting
you I told you to wait at the beer town
while I look for my sandals Oh sick beer
bongs loose that bag airborne playoff no
wait that's uh oh my god Gary he's
drinking all of it I'm feeling sick go
go go go go bro you don't like Coachella
2k15 titties in my mouth
[Music]
hey guys I'm looking to cop a stick
transition tank for the rest of festival
season if you have any cool suggestions
of sites for online stores post in the
comments below also if anyone has a DIY
guide to cleaning a camel pack that'd be
great